[Musique]
c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs pour ce
qu'on appelle le monde d'après
reconstruire une économie plus
écologique plus verte sur les gravats
que des sera le coville 19,1 en jeu tels
que l'onu a déclaré que si cette relance
était suffisamment écolo elle pourrait
permettre de freiner le réchauffement
climatique et réduire les émissions de
co2 prévu jusqu'en 2030 de 25%
et ce n'est pas tout puisque les ong wwf
france a dévoilé en juillet dernier un
scénario selon lequel elle pourrait
permettre de créer un million d'emplois
d'ici 2022 en france et 1,8 millions
d'ici 2030 dans les secteurs clé de la
rénovation des énergies renouvelables de
la mobilité de l'agriculture et du
tourisme la relance verte c'est
simplement faire en sorte que la
production et l'économie en général se
réinvente se transforme en prenant en
compte la protection de l'environnement
et la planète tout en créant de l'emploi
et en engrangeant de l'argent évidemment
sinon ce n'est pas une relance en somme
profiter de la crise pour tout revoir en
profondeur et pour cela pas 36 solutions
il faut investir et massivement wwf
préconise par exemple plusieurs dizaines
de milliards d'investissements sur dix
ans pour atteindre son objectif de
créations d'emplois le gouvernement lui
a également investi 30 milliards sur les
100 milliards de son plan de relance
sont dédiés à la transition écologique
bon c'est moins que la partie
compétitivité des entreprises qui
représentent 35 milliards mais faut pas
trop en demander non plus comme sur les
conditions contre la garantie de l'état
pour les fameux p.geo pas vraiment de
conditions contraignantes sur la
pollution imposé aux grosses entreprises
mauvaise pour l'environnement petit air
france ou renault juste des
recommandations en quelque sorte
décidément à défaut d'une relance verte
il faudra sans doute se contenter d'une
relance vert pâle voire d'une relance
tout court et encore
[Musique]